ça y est le week-end est parti les
valeureux guerriers sont presque prêts
pour le combat
heureusement les femmes sont là pour
attacher les armures et les protections
on se dirige enfin vers le lieu du
scénario les deux groupes vont enfin
pouvoir se tester
l'arrco ni les rouges donc sont la
poursuite de rebelles balle que les
jaunes qu'on doit être accepté dans les
bois c'est juste un petit tournoi qui
est organisée de façon un peu informelle
mais histoire de la muse un peu tout le
monde
les combats au corps à corps vont
continuer jusqu'à la fin de la nuit
la centaine de soldats ne lâche rien le
principe
durant trois jours les amateurs peuvent
se défier en petit comité
cd vraiment des dégâts et des femmes
d'ailleurs des hommes et des femmes qui
viennent chercher plus plus plus combat
que qu'au mois d'août c'est beaucoup
plus c'est moins agressif moins violent
là bon il n'y a rien rien de dangereux
mais on va quand même un peu plus haut
tas
et pendant ce temps-là l'intendance suit
car il faut nourrir tout ce petit monde
comme à l'époque médiévale
après l'effort le réconfort leur de
ripailles est venu au menu cochonnailles
et cervoise viendront ponctuer les
combats des soldats de ces lointaines
contrées